[Music]
this [ __ ] guy
big
gay gay
lion mark carly hella excuse me so
literally this whole i still can't get
over the fact
that this guy made a whole show
about
[ __ ]
haters of course
well i mean to be fair i didn't think
his friend was going to make an entire
special but
[Music]
okay um
so hella mark harley as we all know
brandon's bff
stupid name
guys it's hella mark carter i told you
guys yeah hey mark carly was my dad call
me hella you know that that was one he
just kept
like you know he had to ask brendan too
to be like yo i need you to like
really like astroturf that for me
because if i keep saying it they're not
gonna take it seriously now virgie knows
why i'm so excited about this video
because i looked ahead
i am so excited okay
trick you into responding the only way
that would be appropriate it's like
you're telling me you're gay but also
that you're deeply closeted so he would
never admit that he's gay that's called
a rhetorical trick we're gonna go right
into hella rhetorical let's examine that
sentence just kidding you know we
actually gonna go straight to
a new segment i'm calling hot chick of
the week now we had this absolutely
guys i came up with this so no bro
it's so much better than you please
before you comment this is important
before you do it's important you see the
check it's important the woman is the is
no before we even see the woman okay
okay okay okay
did he literally just go
guys i'm gonna [ __ ] blow your tits
off here with this new thing i just came
up with it's a new segment that i'm
rolling out uh don't judge me too hard
because i just came up with this my gran
we're gonna pick a chick once a week
we're gonna do hot [ __ ] of the week
after war the roses which he also
invented
is is he getting his stuff from prep
burger now he's the last guy with an
account
dude later on we're gonna be doing prank
calls with carmen oh god jesus christ
that'd be [ __ ] great
morning too [ __ ] big gay lion i'm
sorry i knew
that i was now i want to see the chick i
just that already kills me
my new thing i call hot chick of the
week beauty submitted to us
earlier this week and i thought wow what
is her name what is her number i want to
get into contact with her
look at those that's him and drac it's
him and drag it's him and drag
it's him in drag
it's him in drag
[ __ ] versus face
[Laughter]
here
go ahead it's fine
um the funniest [ __ ] on this show
break
watching the little bit of hope
he had left just get
just get extinguished
yeah
but why though
because he looks super good
[Laughter]
someone said he looks like china
why
but why though
you know what no i know i because
i don't know i i don't know it was bugs
bunny day at the san francisco comedy
college
no money python day
i like that's something funny about bugs
bunny yeah
um okay is he going
to explain this are we going to get some
context about this
i guess we'll see cheeks look at those
lips and uh according to her she's all
natural so
hey roy it'll make yes
cute goodbye horses
as he talks about how hot he is in draft
uh
here it is
take them like they used to huh what's
going on here
what's going on is this actually
this is me dressed as a woman all right
i'm going to come clean i am going to
kind of clean up yes now you guys know
what i do on the weekend so when you
come and say hey how you know sup fool
what's going on what'd you do this
weekend one part that i've been leaving
out is the fact that i dress up like a
woman for fun i'd smash
uh you and every other guy
on planet earth i think it's safe to say
this picture came up somebody actually
sent it to me they're scrolling you know
it's from 20 is a bit
i guess he's about to say where it's
from 2017
when i was on
50 central and a couple sketches i would
do
markeisha this is actually a funny
little cult find me markeisha find me
markeisha find me marquisha
find me marcus these guys
this guy sucks
so much
more merch
you know what he probably did markeisha
san francisco comedy college
well he probably that's where he
developed it early on yeah like the well
i got the the early parts of the
character right when i was working my
stuff out at the san francisco comedy
college yeah like like chris farley did
with matt foley at second city like it's
the same thing you know
i uh graduated magna [ __ ] loudly
anyway hot trick of the week is coming
up so this is relax
cultural commentary i think
i have no problem dressing up like a
girl for laughs what you do see is that
it's a lot of work putting on nails
doing the hair and makeup you know
getting on a dress even just doing it to
this degree
it's like you know to do makeup
effectively
you're either hiring somebody like this
a couple times i'm like i want to do
sketch as a girl that'd be funny then
i'm like well then i would have to like
do makeup every time if i want to look
stunningly gorgeous like i do in this
picture um
bro
if he did that markeisha thing what is
he he disappeared it from the internet i
still
i'm not
what is what what
this guy this guy breaks my brain i know
what is the point of you sir
this you're just talking and i feel like
you're trying to do a bit but there's no
energy behind it
there's no confidence behind it
and it's
more work than i want to do but
i was gonna say
when they came to us and had some sketch
ideas
i was the only white person on the cast
he was the jim carrey of that cast
[Music]
that be t thing because remember he was
on bt doing that rap thing this is
probably some bt [ __ ]
bro we have to find this man we get to
find i'm already on it it's 50 cent had
a [ __ ] uh okay sketch comedy show
called 50 central
right yeah and i'm i'm digging for it
i'm already [ __ ] on it okay good
the the other black men on the cast
the other cast members who were men were
black i should say
they
got it in no way give me
give me give me give me give me
where are you dropping it
show links okay hold on two seconds two
seconds oh my god i got it
i don't know if it's markeisha but it's
mark harley and [ __ ]
drag girl you got them shoulders like
serena
the sheet taken
what's what's the matter
you're welcome
you let a bunch of black people dress
you up like a chick and ritualistically
make fun of you well because we always
do it to them i think
i think this i'm not jewish i'm just
saying but but the way they see it yeah
these guys are like man let's finally
let's get one of these little pretty ass
white boys dress him up you think he
smashed because 50 cent's like the
producer on this probably so he was
probably like
yeah that's man you know how they always
be humiliating brothers and making us
dress up man go get me some pretty ass
white boy won't dress his ass up like a
prague you think 50 smash though
probably yeah because i mean he he did
have sex with chelsea handler so i'm
sure it's about the same thing right
yeah
oh mark has more effeminate hips
damn name's markeisha
yep it's markeisha we found markeisha
just make up like something else like
that's a terrible name
i mean yeah you're right but he's
marquis is talking to someone who's
called 50 cent so we're not on the
[ __ ] normal name bandwagon to begin
with markeisha is just what black
writers think is funny like shannane or
shaqwanda like whenever like jamie foxx
or martin short dressed as a woman
or not martin short martin lawrence
dresses a woman
they just always name their name plus
she she or croatia and that's what they
think is funny
that's not that's what this guy is a
bomb yes
and to compare him to
the great name 50 cent i mean 50 cent's
a great name hey fair enough come on
that's what a great name for a rapper
back in the day 50 cent okay okay
look oh thank you i actually take after
my father like your father yep
i can see that look before you get any
bright ideas i am taken and my
boyfriend's nearby
mark you're enjoying that too much
man-to-man why did you do this yeah
i wouldn't need to you don't need to do
this bud
i mean maybe you do
maybe he does need to do this oh oh does
that make it worse
okay look i'm not gonna play anymore
because this is technically on bet's
youtube network and
i mean they don't know how litigious
they are maybe they are i'm sure they do
it afternoon but still
wanted to dress up as women and i don't
know if that's a broader cultural thing
or
like dave chappelle influence wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what did he holy should we miss
something dude
listen listen what he just said i backed
up a little bit asked the other cast
members who were men were black i should
say they
in no way wanted to dress up as women
none of the black guys wanted to dress
up as women
and i don't know if that's a broader
cultural thing
or no it's because they've been having
it done to them for so long that they
know it's some kind of gay-ass
humiliation ritual and a lot of young
black guys have just [ __ ] had it
because they're believe it or not
contrary to popular belief there's a lot
of young black men that are [ __ ]
based yeah good point dave chappelle
influenced people to do that because
remember he was on inside the actor's
studio talking about how
there's like this notion that
when a black man gets too famous
they emasculate you by putting you in a
dress
and they try to get him to do that i
know it's gonna be hilarious on you know
chappelle's show and he's like no man i
don't do that um
everyone has different cultures and
different boundaries and so it's like
that would make sense to me especially
if you have if you knew you were gonna
get a lot of [ __ ] for it or whatever i
can see doing that yeah right the bass
black guy won't put on a dress a big gay
lion such as yourself will yeah that's
right you you you thought yourself
lesser than them or in some way we're
trying to virtue signal so hard or
you're like you're right i'll take the
bullet for you or the fact that you
[ __ ] where else are you going to work
one don't have this or how about this i
get to meet 50 cent
oh god that's probably the truth it's
probably all it was that's probably all
it was so i jumped at the opportunity if
you google 50 cent steals another man's
girl on youtube i'm not saying we're
gonna watch it here but who would ever
google that that's a very specific
you will see me
one of the sketches look up look up uh
bobo redub
sorry
i i [ __ ] love i know
um
clown pewter what the [ __ ] is that
might as well just jack off
someone put it on youtube
he put it up
it was uploaded three hours ago and it
has one view
did you put this video up what the [ __ ]
is that wait so like someone's dubbing
over bozo or
bro he pro it's so funny too because you
only needed a 30 second thing to put but
like yeah he probably had so much fun
doing this part
before they even filmed the sketch
[ __ ] and also the audio quality is so
bad it's like from a webcam
bet it ain't got no [ __ ] games on it
i did dress this girl as markeisha
is on youtube and i love it
one of my favorite sketches from that
show
and jasmine brown's dressed up as a guy
and she's
hilarious like when i show people how
jasmine brown actually looks in real
life compared to the character that she
does reggie the mechanic
they're shocked
okay now that we got that out of the way
that i
am in fact a beautiful woman
he's owning the haters because he
somebody found that picture made fun of
him yeah and what he's doing and he's
like this doesn't affect me
i don't care that i can explain why
black dudes aren't doing something and i
thought that i don't care i'll feel
[ __ ] [ __ ] you got it whatever you
need hey mark
you put on a good game face
but buddy i see right through you
i see right through you would you would
you have sang mammy if they told you to
the internet
is gonna the more you do this
and puff your little chest out the more
the internet's gonna
like wanna break you and no amount of
test with tren and d-ball and all that
is gonna make a [ __ ] difference
especially when you make a show about
the [ __ ] haters [ __ ] haters man
[ __ ]
okay anyway
sorry we didn't play anymore i mean that
that's that's obviously the main part i
wanted to show you as you can see why